wait for it it's time for another
challenge Charlie in today's episode of
challenge charlie I have been challenged
by this person to make my own Charlie so
cool like superhero costume and as
someone who has an entire drawer in
their bedroom dedicated just to dressing
up clothes I'm not joking I thought this
would be the perfect challenge for me to
try not to take but before I can make
the costume I have to show you what I've
designed today is going to be a very
effeminate day for Charlie tada
that's ladies and gentlemen is clothing
Charlie I came to this after thinking if
Charlie is so cool like we're a
superhero what superhero would he be and
I thought seeing as I've done quite a
lot of cloning in my videos making
duplicates of myself cloning Charlie
would be the right way to go he's
essentially multiple man from x-men but
um he's purple and me I put a lot of
detail into this probably more than I
should have been bothered to this is the
cloning Charlie emblem I made it so that
it's like a single cell that is going
through asexual reproduction and is
cloning itself see look at that I care
way too much and then the mask has the
same design oh so are two things that
aren't typical about this superhero one
he wears running shoes spider-man never
wore shoes his feet must have hurt so
bad and the second thing is that
superheroes usually do their best to
hide their identity whereas I'm calling
mine cloning charlie it's like if
Ironman had called himself Tony man so
without further ado let's make a costume
right now I have some green gloves a
purple t-shirt some green y-fronts a
green cape some purple tights some
running shoes safety pins superglue and
elastic and finally some assorted felts
to make the emblem and the mask a very
very effeminate day for Charlie there's
a C 2 C's clothing Charlie we're getting
there the emblem is all stuck together
now so I'll stick it to the t-shirts the
t-shirts done now let me just attach a
cape I have a cape I have a cape I just
need to make the mask out of this and
then I'll be a superhero well I'll be a
teenager in his bedroom pretending to be
a superhero but um hello yeah I think it
needs eye holes there we go right I
think it's time to suit up
ready
okay all right I can't see anything in
this thing and I've cut the eye holes
out so badly well here I am cloning
Charlie I am a superhero these are
essentially just boob patches and I'm
wearing purple tights which are a little
bit see-through as well so oh well I'm
having fun I do like the Cape I will
admit that I like the cane quite a lot
and do I never knock to my masculinity
points today the tights feel quite nice
I mean they do and just to make sure
that you've seen these as well green
boyfriends and running shoes remember
when I was talking about the design of
the costume and how excited I was well
now I just feel like an idiot
so I hope you're happy Oh what is this
oh okay
Charlie yes what do you wear I don't
know well you look like an idiot you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool breast patches rest
patches rest patches rest patches